[Music]
what's going on everybody ian harditz
here i got some late round wide
receivers i think you should be paying
attention to if your fantasy football
draft is still this weekend maybe just
on the waiver wire again guys adp well
outside the top 100 not top eight top
nine round guys but you guys know how
the drafts look early on it's all loaded
until we get to the second half that's
when champions are decided so just a
handful of wide receivers i think can
help your roster really regardless of
format wide receiver threes mostly but
they're in great enough offenses with a
little bit of hidden upside there that i
don't think is being fully baked into
their adp so first up tyler boyd back to
back wide receiver 36 for the cincinnati
bengals in terms of ppr points per game
going outside the top 50 even 60 wide
receivers sometimes he would be in the
wide receiver 2 conversation immediately
with an injury to either t higgins or
jamar chase don't forget about joshua
palmer we'll see if jalen guyton's still
you know rotating in with the wide
receivers but if mike williams goes down
keenan allen goes down let's face it not
the two healthiest receivers we've seen
in the league over the years joshua
palmer now all of a sudden has a chance
to beat justin herbert's regular wide
receiver two got to take a look at kj
hamler i love cortland sutton i love
jerry judy but the thing that everyone's
missing with tim patrick being truly out
of the picture it's not gonna be four
wide receivers in denver it's gonna be
three hamlet has a chance to be i don't
want to say the next tyler locket he's
pretty damn good in his own right but kj
hamler with all that deep fuel
stretching speed don't be surprised if
he's on the other end of some of those
russell wilson moon balls sooner rather
than later jalen tober with the cowboys
already getting the you know nice boost
from having the michael gallup situation
up in the air kj osborne with the
vikings the cooper cup roll for justin
jefferson who cares guys he's justin
jefferson but with sean mcvay's los
angeles rams now expecting that offense
in minnesota under new head coach kevin
o'connell we did see more 11 personnel
three wide receivers than just about any
offense out there so kj osborne's going
from now really a part-time role to a
full-time role and wants to get an
injury to justin jefferson or adam
thielen all of a sudden he's gonna be on
the cover of most of those waiver wire
articles following that unfortunate
event also got to take a look at russell
gage 30 million reasons why the
buccaneer should still keep him plenty
involved in the offense and again people
wide receiver threes got gauge maybe
even the wide receiver 4 behind julio
jones i understand normally these aren't
the players we want but at the adp with
tom brady under center yes russell gage
is still firmly in play and finally got
ron dale moore isaiah mckenzie once
again catching pass from kylo murray
josh allen sends a trend here guys want
these wide receiver threes wide receiver
fours and explosive offenses so again
tyler boyd josh palmer kj handler jalen
tolbert kj osborne russell gage ron
delmore and isaiah mckenzie just a
handful of sleepers i am looking to
really target in the later rounds a
fantasy football drafts of all shapes
and sizes ahead of 2022 but guys let's
get this show rolling welcome to br
fantasy presented by state farm i am
your host ian hardis you know my lovely
employer pro football focus gotta love
the br fantasy fam as well but we are
here today to execute a mock draft
thanks to our good friends over at
sleeper going to be starting out the 108
spot 10 team league half point ppr again
with sleeper this is a mock draft we're
going to have the cpus rolling so it's
not perfect but still a good start for
you that don't have your fantasy drafts
done just yet so we're gonna go ahead
and pull up the stream now and get
things started
again special thanks to the lovely folks
over at sleeper at the 108 the one thing
i'm going to stress throughout this
stream guys is not to panic you know
just like will ferrell and old school
after he got burnt to a freaking crisp
trying to jump through that flaming hoop
what do you say don't panic keep your
composure that's the key here you can
really at the start of these drafts
first three rounds do pretty much
anything you want in terms of the
running backs and wide receivers like i
said before these top three top four
rounds it gets to a situation where
every team is going to look great
because every team's picking between the
top 30 top 40 players it's more of a
matter of once you get into the mid
later rounds that's when we got to make
sure we're filling out the right ross
response before it can be too late so
just looking at the board right now
already had six running backs go off the
board and cooper cup honestly guys if
you see justin jefferson anywhere past
the 103 pick that's my guy i know
there's christian mccaffrey and jonathan
taylor we can have that one-on-one
debate another guy but if after
mccaffrey and jonathan taylor i want
justin jefferson on the squad i did have
cooper cop ahead of justin jefferson for
a decent amount of the summer but with
that matthew stafford the elbow injury
that honestly the rams are being pretty
upfront about not knowing a ton about
enough uncertainty for me to take on
justin jefferson year three i don't want
to say breakout because of course the
man's already broken out arguably the
best start to a career in nfl history at
the wide receiver position absolutely
stoked to get justin jefferson here at
the 108.
appreciate the chat rolling in
definitely get to a bunch of you guys
specific questions later but from a
friedman talking about t higgins good
enough wide receiver one and a 10 man
full league ppr
absolutely man if you find yourself
getting the running back value t higgins
is someone that if you go to sharp
drafts best ball just the leagues where
people are putting down a lot more money
and you can reasonably expect them
hopefully expect them to know a little
bit more what they're talking about
haynes is going regularly among the top
eight top 10 wide receivers once you
move over to sites like sleeper espn
yahoo t higgins is available in round
three so now is like the king time of
you know hot take season i've even seen
people do the t higgins is gonna
outscore jamar chase thing which no i'm
not going that far but either way if we
are going to target a number two wide
receiver that early might as well be
someone as talented as t higgins with a
quarterback like joe burrow so at the
wrap around here pick 2.03
had naji harris jamar chase deandre
swift and davonte adams go off the board
between my picks so travis kelsey is on
the board this isn't a terrible spot to
take him but there's still these upside
wide receivers and running backs
available i'm gonna get a little quirky
here i'm going with stefan diggs i
believe over these running backs i think
alvin kamara's in play here saquon
barkley is in play but for me i have
justin jefferson as my overall wide
receiver one step on diggs as my 104.
i'm going to see what happens here by
locking in stefan diggs and just really
starting with two absolute baller wide
receivers like guys particularly in digs
case gabriel davis isaiah mckenzie
dawson knox okay there are some candice
to be that number two guy in buffalo i'm
not against them but if we look at
diggs's you know ultimate just uh i
guess best case scenario here in buffalo
he could legit have a target total
starting with a two by the time it is
all over with so looking at now pick
three eight
zeko elliott aj brown and james connor
on the board kyle pitts as well so this
is a situation where i'm between kyle
pitts and actually uh james connor here
so looking at the kind of options i've
already got two wide receivers i gotta
wonder what running back's gonna come
back to me ah this is a tough one so i
do think kyle pitts in round three has
you know the opportunity to be someone
that we're gonna look back on in 2023
and say how the heck was kyle pitts
someone with legit 100 340 target
potential how is he even available in
round three
with that said james connor guys he's
too good to lose here i'm go ahead and
lock in james connor at the 3 8 there so
really when you think about
what james connor can bring the table
what have we talked about you know all
off season who's going to take the chase
edmonds role in this offense because as
we saw james connor before that chase
edmonds injury he was someone that was a
little bit more of a touchdown dependent
rb2 but once edmonds did get hurt guys
james connor he was legit ripping off
games with a 90 plus 90 plus snap rate
so when i see eno benjamin a former
seventh-round pick kiante ingram another
sixth seventh round pick and daryl
williams someone that's making the vet
minimum in arizona i think the answer
for who's gonna get to chase edmonds
role is james connor he's now one of
only 11 running backs in the nfl making
over 20 million dollars per year and
don't be fooled this guy can catch the
football so the injury concerns are a
little bit warranted but guys this is
james connery he's healthy right now the
cardinals again have over 20 million
reasons why they should feed him the
football as much as possible and we have
seen that from clip kingsbury over the
years so very confident in james connor
in round three really does have the
workload more so of an rb1
as i'm into round four now i could look
at taking a tight end like a george
kittle but guys i just think with
ezekiel elliott still on the board here
again i started off with two two wide
receivers zeke for me looking at the
value i mean 27 player overall still
available here with the next closest
being michael pittman at 34. i'm going
to go ahead and take zeke at this range
i haven't gotten a ton of zeke this all
season but it ultimately comes down to
what do we think the cowboys are gonna
do with this offense probably feed the
ball to zeke that's what they say every
time we happen to go through it you know
and someone decides to put a microphone
in front of jerry jones's face and hey i
agree that tony pollard is better maybe
not better but he's more efficient than
zeke and my god he's more explosive in
the year 2022 i still think zeke and the
past blocking game and some of the you
know nuanced ability to pick up five
yards was only three there things maybe
that don't translate quite as well over
to a highlight reel you can talk about
that there about the end of day zeke is
still someone looking at over 300
touches in the reigning number one
scoring offense so if you want to look
at zeke and question the overall upside
fine i look at zeke and i see a fourth
down version of nashi harris that's just
too much volume to bust in fantasyland
so shout out style clash michael pittman
or mike evans i am going to go with mike
evans i think they have a similar target
ceiling yes evans has more overall
competition in his offense but when you
look at tom brady coming off a year in
which he led the league in total
dropbacks even if evans is the 1a and
pittman's like the clear number one i
still think just with the overall pass
game volume available in tampa bay mike
evans is someone we can get there and
you know how many times does mike evans
just need to score 10 plus touchdowns
get over a thousand yards before we put
this man and the true top five wide
receivers where he belongs so
through four rounds james connor ezekiel
elliott at running back justin jefferson
and stefan diggs out wide receiver i got
a lot of you know just versatility here
in terms of what i'm able to do with the
rest of my lineup so i've had some
rosters that start with three running
backs some with three wide receivers
being at 2-2 here gives me a lot of
potential to do just about anything so i
am gonna go ahead and keep loading up at
wide receiver with cortland sutton here
i'm thinking russell wilson's number one
wide receiver those have been the
reports out of training camp and yes
with cortland sutton it was really
disappointing last year to see exactly
what went down uh in denver because we
saw teddy bridgewater and carolina
enabled three top 30 wide receivers and
dj moore robbie anderson and curtis
samuel and to really have the answer
last year to be no in terms of who's
actually going off here
in that offense maybe you could say tim
patrick for a stretch of that year but
come on like we still weren't feeling
great about firing up tim patrick i am a
little bit concerned about sutton and
judy and the overall upside here but
when i can get sutton here after guys
like deontay johnson you know mike
williams michael pittman really all
these wide receiver twos have some
problems in their profile there's at
least one red flag for basically every
wide receiver going after the first 10
or 11 even someone like aj brown like we
know these guys are great
but they are in some offenses where we
just don't need to exactly feel
fantastic about but colton sutton on the
board at this point guys i am go ahead
and take darren waller and secure my
tight end spot so darren waller someone
that if you've been paying attention to
some of the training camp reports hasn't
been practicing a ton really does seem
more and more likely that that was just
purely due to a contract dispute though
so he is now under you know the tutelage
of um rosen house i believe agency and
he is now going to be looking at getting
potentially a fat contract extension
right before the season so um i believe
it's kevin nash that wrestler back in
the day you guys have probably seen that
gif of him in the wheelchair he's in a
wheelchair he's got the cast there then
all of a sudden he just stands up and
he's perfectly fine that's kind of how
i'm anticipating darren waller being
once week one rolls around so no doesn't
have the same gaudy ceiling as in past
years because of someone like devonte
adams and hunter renfro potentially now
being derek carr's top two pass game
options but just the overall talent
profile with darren waller he is you
know going to have his age getting in
the early 30s here sooner rather than
later still though tight ends we have
seen execute at a high level into the
early stages of their career far better
than any other position basically other
than quarterbacks so darren waller in
round six very happy to scoop him up
there and 12 team leagues i am fine
getting one of waller or kittle in round
five
as i'm on the board here now joe burrow
jalen hurts looking at quarterback and i
really do think it's a tear drop off
after hertz i do not understand how joe
burrow is ahead of jalen hurts i will
happily take hurts instead so who would
i rather take on my real life team
burrell over hurts a hundred times out
of a hundred we're not drafting a real
live team though we're drafting a
fantasy team and just from what we've
seen over the years with these dual
threat quarterbacks they really are the
closest thing that we have to a cheat
code look at the players that we always
hype up receiving running backs and the
quarterbacks that can run the ball every
now and then we even get a debo samuel
the wide receiver that gets rush
attempts these players that literally
have two entirely separate means of
getting production they're just playing
like a different game against some of
these statue quarterbacks like a borough
like a brady so jaylen hurts last year i
think we saw a similar thing to kind of
rookie year lamar jackson or you know
the first two years of josh allen's
career not quite a good real life
quarterback yet but still a fantasy star
now with aj brown town i think we can
see hurts to be both a fantasy god and
maybe not quite a real-life god but at
least a very good quarterback on an
eagles team that really doesn't have a
weakness across the entire roster
here's a situation now in the draft
where i already got my two running backs
and james connor and ezekiel elliott i'm
not full at this point i got my
quarterback i got my tight end i'm gonna
drop my kicker and defense in the last
two rounds where they belong so with
this in mind i am gonna go ahead and get
gabriel davis and he's one of these guys
too where i've talked about the
differences that we see you know and
more sharper leagues in terms of that
adp and also leagues that are more espn
yahoo based not saying your home league
isn't sharp guys i'm not trying to
insult anyone out there but just based
on the adps you look at gabriel davis
and a lot of these leagues where it's
costing a lot more money to enter he's
regularly going off the board as a top
20 top 25 wide receiver being able to
get him again in the early stages of
round eight even if this was a 12-man
draft we're still talking at about a
value in round six round seven and once
we get into kind of this wide receiver
stage now i'm really happy that i
already have four players at the
position so
this has been my preferred build through
a lot of the off-season try get two
running backs in the first few rounds
get an upside tie-down when they fall
maybe get an upside quarterback in round
six or seven when they fall but
otherwise load up at wide receivers so
i'm gonna go back to the well one more
time here because to me there's a pretty
big drop off after elijah moore and i
will start to get some of these running
backs that tend to fall to this range as
well so for me this is another big kind
of edge that you can have in drafts of
all shapes and sizes just with the way
adp is falling here we usually don't
have these running backs available at
this point in drafts that have the
upside as the players on the board for
me guys like
cordero patterson kareem hunt who are
off the board here but they kind of fit
this criteria chase edmonds andre
stevenson even melvin gordon these are
players that you're not absolutely
thrilled about starting as your rb1 per
se but rb3 like it is in this roster or
even just an rb4 flex type there's a lot
of upside here they're explosive pass
catching options who are all one injury
away from really just leaping into the
top twelfth of the position potentially
so i'm going to scoop up ramondre
stevenson someone that's really been the
talk of the fantasy football industry
for a lot of this off
i didn't quite see it at first i'll be
honest we've seen new england running
backs over the years and trying to
figure out who's going to lead that
committee is typically wishful thinking
it's why we always say you know go ahead
and just take the cheapest guy available
but in stevenson's case
we want a running back that can get that
pass roll because the upside attached to
the early down backs really hasn't been
there damien harris scored 15 touchdowns
last year and he was the rb18 and ppr
points for game what about the
legarrette blunt year he scored 18
touchdowns he was the rb 15 and ppr
points per game i don't know why one
reception in this case half point ppr i
i think i don't think it adds up like
one reception being worthy of 10 rushing
or receiving yards i don't think is
equivalent but it's the game we play and
for that reason guys like james white
stefan ridley they've actually been the
better new england running backs to
target so romandre stevenson with james
white retired with time montgomery
banged up with jj taylor and kevin
harris now off the roster hey it took us
again quite a few things to get here but
romantic stevenson is shaping up as the
1b on early downs behind damon harris
and the potential pass down running back
that's sort of the upside i am looking
for in round 10. so as it stands now on
the board
i already have let's see four wide
receipts five wide receivers and three
running backs so i'm comfortable getting
another running back at this point
between michael carter and alexander
madison
i'm actually gonna go with daryl
henderson here
if it was full ppr i would look really
long and hard at name hines the colts
backup running back because not only
with matt ryan under center and all the
you know lovely things frank reich has
said my goodness colts head coach frank
wright back in march was telling us to
draft knight heinz to our fantasy
leagues i wasn't so much buying that but
when you look at name hines and what he
did in the preseason every single first
team snap alongside matt ryan phillip
lindsay actually got cut i think they
might have brought him back the practice
squad but either way name hines i
thought of a more so as jd mckissick
someone where even if the starter gets
hurt their role might not change that
much now guys if scott forbid something
happens to jonathan taylor 99 heinz can
be a top 15 maybe even top 12 back
sooner rather than later so with that
sort of handcuff upside full ppr love
name hines i'm very happy to get daryl
henderson you know i talked earlier
about cliff kingsbury
being one of very few coaches who is
actually willing to give their starting
running back a true workhorse 80 90 snap
roll sean mcvay's another one willing to
do that out there in la so happy to get
henderson looking at my roster at this
point i now have james connor ezekiel
elliott daryl henderson and randra
stevenson at rb i'm gonna get one more
go ahead
i just talked up knight in hinds that's
kind of lame to pick him after that
let's go with michael carter here the
starting running back for the jets for
now i know bruce hall is going to get
there eventually but the thing with
carter again similar to daryl henderson
these are guys where
if you guys listen to the fantasy
footballers absolutely love them but
mike wright actually coined this term
because i was asking twitter one day
what do we call the running back where
okay you can throw them into flex they
might get 10 to 15 combined carries and
targets per week you're not feeling
great but the handcuff upside is sky
high shout out mike wright flex with
benefits that's what we're calling these
running backs now so daryl henderson and
michael carter i think really fit that
bill because even if bruce hall is going
to eventually become the starter in this
backfield still a really good chance
it's going to be a 1a1b situation all
those numbers that you know we've talked
about with javonte williams and the
missed tackle sports per carry and the
yards after contact for kerry last year
guys javonte williams was number one
running back and forcing missed tackles
per touch in terms of pff's advanced
statistics number two michael carter so
i don't know what they're putting in
that north carolina water cooler but
both these guys very talented and again
to get a guy with that potential in
round 12 i am absolutely fine getting
these running backs late i love this
range of the position
i'm feeling content at running back and
wide receivers so i'm looking at the
best player involved what about the
sleeper wide receiver i talked up
earlier one tyler boyd again we've
actually gotten a nice sample size of
about 12 games where tyler boy has
played without one of t higgins or jamar
chase t higgins was banged up for a good
portion of last year obviously jamar
chase wasn't in the nfl during joe
burrows rookie season so tyler boyd 12
games without higgins or jamar chase
once we actually extrapolate that to 17
he is on pace for 147 targets so this is
not your typical number three wide
receiver where okay the number two goes
down and maybe just someone else steps
up or the offense decides to run the
ball more we've seen tyler boy boyd be
leaned on over the years he's managed to
put up big production and he continues
to be priced oh so close to his floor
compared to the ceiling so love being
able to get tyler boyd and around
freaking 13 here as other people are
taking defenses and kickers which i now
need to do now so
sometimes i would advise not taking
kickers or defenses at all because you
can take a running back and maybe things
get funky by the time week one comes
around and you know value's probably not
gonna change much on the kicker defense
but it certainly could at rb i will say
out of this group of defenses there are
a few that i'm targeting the
indianapolis colts are who i'm gonna
settle on here so really there's four
defenses of special teams four of them
guys that i think you should be looking
to draft in the second to last round of
your drafts the colts the broncos the
browns and the 49ers that was the fourth
one so each of these teams i think
they're good enough in the front seven
like you look at denver even though they
don't have von miller anymore being able
to get randy gregory from the cowboys
hopefully a healthy version of chubb
down there as well they we could see
that pass rush going well and getting to
start the season with seattle and
houston how could you not love that
indianapolis first two games they're
going to be facing davis mills and
trevor lawrence the 49ers are going to
be having a fully healthy nick bosa
which has really taken their defense
over the top in recent years also a nice
nice soft start to the season excuse me
uh for them and the cleveland browns the
one defense that we really have a chance
to get the first four weeks of the year
now jacoby brissett under center thinks
they're a little bit shoddy there so
part of my pff contract i don't talk
about kickers but we'll take rodrigo
blankenship because uh he wears rec
specs and it's kind of funny sometimes
so that's about the depth of my kicker
evaluation but they are in the colts
offense i i kid a little bit here guys
but yes that is going to be the squad
and got to feel good when you can match
up the kicker with the defense so
quickly to recap
again 10 team league half point ppr
picking out of the 108 spot quarterback
i got jalen hurts you do not need a
second quarterback if you get someone
like jalen hurts even someone like you
know trey lance if you get any top eight
top ten quarterback don't feel the need
to get a second one james connor or ziko
elliott rb1 rb2 justin jefferson and
stefan diggs along with cortland sutton
and gabriel davis filling out the rest
of my starting lineup also have elijah
moore in the wide receiver room also
tyler boyd tight end darren waller
similar to quarterbacks guys only need
one tight end in these normal one qb
re-draft leagues raimondra stevenson
daryl henderson michael carter some of
those nice flecks of benefits we talked
about colts d and rodrigo blankenship at
the kicker so great day to be great here
guys let's jump into personalized
fantasy advice presented by state farm
where the personal price plan is all
about creating a price just for you now
here chat i appreciate you guys uh
coming along tried to answer some of
those during it but drop's over now i am
all here for you guys so from bcx
echoler over cmc
no
no i'm going cmc i'm not predicting that
this guy is just going to get hurt for
no reason at all he's healthy right now
give me christian mccaffrey over any
running back not named jonathan taylor
and i will take christian mccaffrey over
jonathan taylor in full point ppr
scoring when we look at their potential
range of outcomes guys what if christian
mccaffrey gets hurt what if he doesn't
get hurt you probably win your fantasy
league so like ricky bobby said first or
last maybe you are in a fantasy league
with those last place punishments where
it can get messy so in that case maybe a
little bit safer but generally guys i am
going for the championship and nobody
gives you a better chance to win that
championship at full health than
christian mccaffrey
from ryan b thoughts on aj brown the
talent's there like it's a very similar
situation honestly to tyree kill the
problem is the continuity isn't there
and to be fair this is an offense with
aj brown he's gonna have more target
competition than he's ever had now good
reason in tennessee he's got the best
wide receiver in philly as well but now
he's also probably still in a run first
offense and this time devonta smith and
dallas goddard around there i have aj
brown as my wide receiver 12. love him
way more in round three than round two
from at john smoke who are four players
you refuse to draft i don't have a do
not draft list i think you can have a
setting or a league size or a long
enough draft basically where everyone is
in play with that said at adp i have not
been getting much of nick chubb in the
middle of round two i just think guys
like saquon barkley even leonard
fournette they have the workloads that
we can only dream of nick chubb having
don't blame me blame kevin stefanski for
taking nick chubb off the field on
passing downs for kareem hunt i get but
for dearness johnson come on man also
debo samuel just the volume concerns and
look debo is one of the most talented
players in the league i get it but we're
picking him next to guys like tyree kill
like mike evans like aj brown i think
they're pretty good too and i think they
have a chance to get over 50 targets
more than debo this year depending on
how the tray lance experiment goes
depending on if george kittle and i
continue to take a back seat to him i
just think that's an awfully steep price
to pay for debo samuel i'd also just say
that joe burrows some joe burrow and
josh allen will be the two other guys
where i i love both those players i love
every nfl player you know don't hate the
player hate the adp but josh allen going
in round three when i can get guys like
kyla murray jaylen hurts in round six
it's not just about the quarterback
themselves but you look at round three
the running backs the wide receivers we
can still get there
round six when kylo murray and jay and
hertz are going that's when we're
actually kind of in that dead zone of
running backs and also most of the top
30 top 35 wide receivers are off the
board anyway similar sentiment with joe
burrow in round five versus someone like
tom brady in round eight nine how even
kirk cousins derek carr going literally
50 picks after joe burrow i just think
that's far better value when considering
the price
from maurice putting aside specific
players is there a draft strategy that
you can use i would say maurice don't
panic as we talked about on this uh
stream a few times just if you want to
get a tight end you know if you're in
round five round six with darren waller
and george kittle and they go off the
board don't immediately go to dalton
schultz like don't try to just fill a
need just to fill a need make a strength
a super strength so that'd be my big
advice here when you're going through if
you start off with three four wide
receivers because those are the great
picks hey if your league mates look at
your roster and they say well he's an
rb2 away from you know being like the
number one contender that's a lot better
for me than actually just having this
pretty mid overall roster where you know
you raced on tight end you reson
quarterback just to fill things out so
having done probably about 60 drafts
including best ball this throughout this
off season since the draft normally i
would say superhero rb is my favorite
draft strategy get two running backs in
the top three rounds then we're looking
at four or five wide receivers over the
course of the next few rounds tight end
or quarterback if they fall but there's
enough value later you don't exactly
need to worry about it and then really
being willing to attack the running
backs and tight ends available in rounds
eight through ten guys like coldero
patterson kareem hunt chase edmonds
maybe even the damian pierce depending
on what his adp saying i know he should
be more of a round five guy but you guys
know how this goes sometimes and even
guys like dallas goddard zach ertz and
dawson knox over someone like a dalton
schultz who tends to go much higher than
them
from read the article i got cooks cook
diggs connor pittman hawkinson mike
warrens and then sutton with the ninth
pick with my first six picks yay or nay
only one i don't like there is tj
hawkinson and it's not it's not about tj
hawkinson it's i can get tj hawkinson it
looks like he got him in round five or
around six or so or i can get dallas
goddard zachary and dawson knox rounds
later so when hawkinson and schultz are
going off the board there's really still
a lot of good upside wide receivers
there guys like a monroe st brown
gabriel davis sometimes i just don't
think the difference between hawkinson
and like goddard hertz and even knox is
that big so i'd much rather take those
wide receivers and then get the discount
on tight end later
from at style clash pittman or evans i
do have mike evans by a bit from at
daddy ray damien pierce or miles sanders
what a time to be alive guys i think
it's damian pierce at this point not
because of the marlon mack or royce
freeman cuts but because we have
evidence now based on the preseason
usage that damian pierce is going to be
the starting running back in houston so
i think his chance at getting the full
three down workload is just better than
miles sanders at this point we still
have kenneth gamewell boston scott i
know you don't care about boston scott
but the eagles do care about boston
scott and even trey sermon now in the
equation who the eagles just claimed off
of waivers shortly before we started
talking here so with damian pierce we
want three down explosive running backs
i know the texans offense sucks but
damian pierce has a chance if things go
right to have legit like a hundred more
carries and targets than miles sanders
so even if sanders is the more efficient
player i will chase that volume with
damian pierce
from soggy pierce should get drafted in
seventh or eighth round the texans are
gonna be playing from behind i get it
and it could be rex burkhead early on
but if rex burke had 32 year old rex
burkhead with all due respect to sexy
rexy if he's the only thing standing
between you and a three down roll that's
a bet i'm willing to take you know in
round six or seven so yeah don't get
carried away on damien pierce i've heard
some people saying round four round
three now definitely not there but once
we get to round seven especially round
seven round eight for me that's the
sweet spot for when you can look at
damien pierce especially on rosters
where you only have one or two running
backs and finally at marvin mitchell if
i get the number one overall pick who am
i taking christian mccaffrey in full ppr
jonathan taylor and half ppr and
standard superflex league we have two
quarterbacks josh allen everybody so
gotta love that i want to thank everyone
for tuning in to this edition of br
fantasy it was a fun mock draft got a
lot of the draft questions truly good
luck to everyone in this in your fantasy
drafts this weekend don't be afraid to
be great be a champion again everyone
this has been br fantasy presented by
state farm until next time take care
everybody